[intro music]
Good morning, Hank, it's Monday, February 19th.
President's Day.
Hank, that was Brotherhood 2.0 resident mathematician Daniel Biss!
Daniel's here because his brother Jonathan is playing a concert at Carnegie Hall.
Oh, and speaking of concerts, I've had a lot of fun reading and listening to and watching all of the responses to your video survey.
It turns out that our viewers, by and large, had terrible taste in music when they were children.
Let's just go over some of their first concerts:
*NSYNC
Paula Abdul
Chicago
Huey Lewis and the News
The New Kids on the Block
The Spice Girls
The Oak Ridge Boys
La Toya Jackson
La Toya Jackson?
Who goes to a La Toya Jackson concert?
Did La Toya Jackson ever even make music?
I thought she was just a stripper!
But a couple of our viewers' first concerts were pretty frakkin' awesome.
Lauren K. went to see the Dead Milkmen,
one of our favorite bands,
and she would definitely be the winner for awesomest first concert,
were it not for Christopher, whose first concert was was at the State Fair.
[laughs]
Hold on, hold on.
And featured Weird Al Yankovic opening for the 3 remaining Monkees.
But the most disturbing thing about your first concert question
is that 2 Brotherhood 2.0 viewers have apparently never been to a concert.
Hank, I think it's vitally important that we get Melissa and Amy to a concert as soon as possible
and that's why I am proposing the creation of the Brotherhood 2.0 Concert Scholarship Fund
for Melissa and Amy and Also Possibly Other Brotherhood 2.0 Viewers Who Have Not Been to Concerts.
[sighs] The name is unwieldy, I think we need to work on that.
Anyway, I am going to give $20 to this scholarship fund,
I hope that you will match my pledge.
Hank, the other question I really liked was the question about how you have to invent your own question
and then answer it.
I wanted to answer some of my favorite questions that other people posed.
Kelly Feinmann asks, "If you could own a house in any country in the world other than the U.S.,
where would it be?"
Ireland.
Ally Carter asks, "Is your new book going to be worth all the effort?"
And finally, Laura asks,
"Where's the weirdest place you've ever brushed your teeth?"
Good question!
[rock music plays]
Hank, I'll see you tomorrow.
[rock music continues]